la lectura es un tanto tanto abstracta
principalmente porque todas las
informaciones que hemos ido recibiendo
tanto por un lado como por otro han
resultado ceremonias están
adulteradas no sé exactas en el sentido
estricto de la palabra con la cual ahora
mismo estamos viendo un baile de números
y de cifras y está viendo una
desinformación general como hablamos el
otro día de la intervención militar o
sea no era algo que nadie se estuviese
esperando excepto algunos de los puntos
neurálgicos de el
artista que es lo que ha sucedido desde
entonces desde entonces hemos visto como
incluso los propios propagandista los
gustos los propios medios de
comunicación afiliados al gobierno de
rusia desconocían cuál era la verdadera
intención y estaban todo el tiempo
negando la mayor hemos visto que rusia
ha hecho un órdago que ha preferido
asumir todas las acciones y todo el
ostracismo internacional que puede
llegar a tener y la pregunta ahora es
qué información tenía para tomar esta
decisión hasta el momento ningún de sus
países que se suponen que son clásicos
aliados como podría ser china como diese
venezuela cecilia como podría ser cuba
nadie haya conocido a la independencia
de las provincias hasta el momento hasta
día de hoy rusia está haciendo una
avanzadilla militar en solitario por
todo claro no sólo han llegado a las
provincias del mes y dedo y de bombas
sino que está avanzando por toda la zona
de embarazo qué es lo que va a suceder
habrá una anexión final llegaremos a ver
cómo las tropas rusas están entrando en
quiere ahora mismo es imposible
distinguir qué va a ser desinformación
que va a ser verdad y hasta qué punto la
avanzadilla militar bastante espalda da
con algunos por otros actores
internacionales lo único que está claro
es que rusia ha conseguido movilizar a
todo el sistema de organizaciones
internacionales en su contra
rusia puede realmente hacerle caso a la
comunidad internacional y parar estas
hostilidades no seguir con su incursión
militar pues digamos en un en una señal
de bandera blanca de decir pues bueno
ahora negociamos
en este sentido rus yo también estoy
intentando que se reconociese el golpe
de estado que había habido en función
del 2014 que se reconociese en las
hostilidades que estaba bien habiendo
tanto con contra su propia presencia
contra la propia población en su
variante que habían que había en en
ucrania no se ha intentado que no
hubiese una expansión de la otra que no
hubiese un acercamiento de una de sus
provincias históricas de hecho la madre
de las provincias de rusia hacia hacia
el eje atlantista hemos visto como en en
ucrania se ha hecho una demolición
social controlada algo muy parecido a lo
que ha sucedido cataluña en españa han
ido ahora norberto de las relaciones
sociales si bien hasta las de unos años
sobre la población en ucrania era
independientemente craneal
independientemente a todos tenían una
base común todos eran aislados todos
tenían una cultura cómoda y conocida no
había un conflicto social desde el 2014
esto se ha minado se había prohibido la
lengua rusa se había atacado a las
complicidades a las vitales justas se
había sacado la economía la economía
rusa dentro de él dentro de ucrania
la comunidad internacional simplemente
no había hecho nada
que se complete en diversos acuerdos de
greens que no se estaban cumpliendo
porque había estaba viendo
intervenciones militares le gritó y
peravia no en las provincias de donde es
uno cas y la comunidad internacional no
ha tenido las organizaciones
internacionales no han tenido ningún
interés en no observa en defender en
preocuparse de ponerle el punto de vista
de rusia este golpe sobre la mesa de
rusia responde a unos problemas internos
y este escenario que están haciendo esta
invasión no se prepara en dos guías esto
era un escenario bien ya preparado como
posibilidad desde hace ya bastante
tiempo ha querido cristalizarse en este
momento veremos a ver cómo acaba
respondiendo las acciones
internacionales o el llamado el jazz la
artista